galactus the Silver Surfer the x-men the
Fantastic Four and Doctor Doom
characters that fans of Marvel have been
waiting to see in the MCU for a very
long time and finally once again Marvel
and Disney owned the rights to these
characters and can bring them into the
MCU officially now and luckily for us
based off of everything that we've heard
it sounds like we won't really have to
wait that long to see them appear in the
MCU how's it going everybody it's Warren
and this is really exciting news but
some even bigger and even more exciting
news is that the Russo brothers the
directors of Avengers in-game Avengers
infinity war Captain America Civil War
and Captain America the Winter Soldier
may be the directors to bring these
characters into the MCU now the Risa
brothers have publicly stated that after
Avengers in game they would be taking a
break from directing anything with
Marvel but fortunately for us it sounds
like these new characters could be just
what the Russo brothers need to come
back to Marvel and direct a film so in
this video I'm going to talk about a
recent interview with the Russo brothers
where they talked about all of the
characters that they would like to
handle in the MCU and talked about how
the Russo brothers said in this video
how they can probably find something to
do soon in terms of characters to bring
in the MCU with Kevin Feige so really
really big news today and I'm going to
break it all down in this video but
first be sure to subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment with your
favorite superhero or villain to enter
my giveaway to win an Xbox one or a ps4
I'm picking a winner at 500,000
subscribers we are less than a thousand
subscribers away so be sure to subscribe
so obviously this news is just super
exciting we didn't expect the rusev
brothers to be back anytime soon and
they did such an amazing job with all of
the movies that they've directed an MCU
each movie that they directed are
arguably the top four movies of the MCU
in its entirety many fans consider
Avengers in game or Avengers infinity
war the best MCU movie of all time and
usually if they don't consider one of
those two the best movie of the MCU they
usually consider Captain America the
Winter Soldier or Captain America Civil
War the best movie of the MCU all
he's directed by the Russo brothers
they've done an outstanding job with the
movies they've directed in the MCU and
like I said in a recent interview
they've talked about what it would take
to bring them back and how they would
probably find something to direct very
soon in the MCU with Kevin Feige so
let's talk about this interview in an
interview with Reese or others and a
sci-fi wire it was brought up that they
said that they would be taking a little
break from directing Marvel movies for
some time but then they asked the Russo
brothers what it would take to bring
them back they said that they're not
ruling out a return and the fact that
Marvel Studios just got the rights to
the x-men and the Fantastic Four it may
be enough to bring them back when asked
if there was anything that could bring
them back Joe Russo said I grew up on
John burns his x-men run Ben Grimm was a
favorite character growing up the thing
and Fantastic Four is now in the Marvel
fold there's a lot so at the end of this
statement Joe Russo literally said that
there is a lot that could bring them
back to direct a Marvel film and when
you think about it Joe and Anthony Russo
said they'd be taking a break for a
while this was right during the time
that the Disney Fox deal was coming to a
close so at that time Marvel and Disney
didn't have access to all these new and
exciting characters and now they do and
it sounds like these characters are
enough to change the directors minds
because Joe Russo went on to say Silver
Surfer is an amazing character going
really big in cosmic would be a lot of
fun so there's a lot of things that
could attract us I mean look working
with Kevin Feige and Luis de espacio and
Victoria Alonso has been the most
rewarding collaboration we've had in our
entire career they're like family to us
now we're all very very close to one
another and we miss each other so I'm
sure we'll find something that we can do
together soon that last line is huge Joe
Russo just said that I'm sure we'll find
something that we can do together soon
referring to Kevin Feige the president
of Marvel Studios and a project to take
on so the Russo brothers have officially
and openly talked about returning to the
MCU to direct another film that's super
exciting news as it is but what makes it
even more
exciting is the type of film that they
would come back to direct because as Joe
Russo said in the interview they're not
going to come back to direct just any
normal film they're not going to come
back to direct a Disney Plus series
they're not going to come back to direct
a Young Avengers film no they're going
to come back to direct a film of one of
the new characters that Disney and
Marvel now have from the Disney Fox deal
so what film could Joe and Anthony Russo
return to direct well in the beginning
of the interview he said that he grew up
on John Burns's x-men run so clearly Joe
and Anthony Russo are x-men fans they
have even openly admitted in an
interview that if they could direct any
MCU film they would want to direct a
Wolverine film and the Russo brothers
coming back to the MCU to direct a
Wolverine film honestly makes perfect
sense because although the Russo
brothers are going to come back they
still are probably going to take a
little bit of a break and we know from
Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios that the x-men aren't coming for
another few years according to him most
likely somewhere between four and five
years so that gives the Russo brothers a
good enough break from Marvel to go on
and direct other films that are not
related to Marvel and then come back to
direct a Wolverine or x-men film and if
you really think about it
Wolverine is going to be an insanely
hard character to introduce into the MCU
and the reason that is is because of
Hugh Jackman he was the perfect
Wolverine everybody loved him and a lot
of people can't really see anybody else
playing Wolverine but Hugh Jackman but
unfortunately he's a little too old to
play Wolverine in the current MCU Marvel
is not going to continue the x-men
stories from the Fox universe all of
those stories are officially done and
will never have happened in the MCU so
unfortunately that means all new
characters and no more Hugh Jackman
Wolverine and we know how Marvel works
we know how the Marvel Cinematic
Universe works all stories and movies
interconnect with one another and they
do this over the course of many years so
whoever signs on to play Wolverine is
really committing to play Wolverine for
the next 10 15 20 years and
unfortunately Hugh Jackman is a little
too old to commit to that and he's
publicly stated that he is definitely
done playing Wolverine so the task of a
new Wolverine is going to be in
mainly hard especially because fans are
going to be judging it hardcore so who
better to bring back on board to direct
a Wolverine or x-men film which
Wolverine will be in than the Russo
brothers they've done such an amazing
job with Marvel in the past and fans
love them and they love the movies that
they direct so in terms of the Russo
brothers returning to direct an x-men
film that is probably pretty high on the
list then of course they mentioned the
Fantastic Four
now the Fantastic Four will probably be
coming to the MCU before the x-men and
the Fantastic Four have a little bit
different problem than the x-men the
problem with the Fantastic Four is the
last two Fox versions of the Fantastic
Four tweren't really that good in fact
fans pretty much hated the film's so
bringing a new Fantastic Four into the
MCU is a very challenging feat as well
especially when you consider the
Fantastic Four will eventually bring in
Galactus now in Fantastic Four and the
rise of the Silver Surfer fans
absolutely hated how they portrayed
Galactus he is one of the biggest
baddest villains of the MCU and fans
absolutely hated him in that movie so
now the big challenges with the
Fantastic Four is making a really good
movie and making a really good version
of Galactus that everybody loves but the
researchers had that challenge with
Thanos Thanos with his Infinity Gauntlet
is one of the most iconic Marvel
villains ever and they did an absolutely
amazing job with vanos infinity war and
endgame where the best Marvel films ever
and as Joe Russo said in the interview
the Russo brothers are huge Fantastic
Four fans
and since they did such an amazing job
with Thanos you know that they could
tackle Galactus as well and of course
with the Fantastic Four comes the Silver
Surfer again fans did not really like
Fantastic Four in the rise of the Silver
Surfer so again the same challenge
making a version of the Silver Surfer
that the fans liked but the cool thing
with the Silver Surfer is they actually
don't have to do a Fantastic Four movie
they could make a movie just about the
Silver Surfer and in this movie they
could start to set up Galactus then from
there they can move on to introduce the
Fantastic Four this would be an amazing
project for the Russo brothers to take
on because as they said they are huge
fantastic for fans and
these are movies that they could do over
the years several movies not just one
you could have a movie just about the
Silver Surfer you could have a couple of
movies just about the Fantastic Four and
Doctor Doom and then of course you could
have a huge team up movie with the
Fantastic Four the x-men and the
Avengers all teaming up to take on
Galactus and of course the Russo
brothers are well experienced in doing
that because we just got infinity war
and endgame so who better than to take
on these projects than the Russo
brothers and Marvel and Kevin Feige they
know that as Joe Russo said they all got
very close and they're all family to
each other and they miss each other and
they have all of these upcoming
characters and projects to do and as Joe
Russo said in the last line of his
interview I'm sure we'll find something
to do together soon so it seems like the
Russo brothers are making their way back
to the MCU and not just to direct any
normal film but to direct an amazing
film that is either the x-men Wolverine
the Fantastic Four the Silver Surfer or
Galactus let me know how excited you are
to hear this news down in the comments
section below and let me know what you
think would be a perfect movie for the
Russo brothers to direct and make their
return to the MCU and again don't forget
to subscribe to my channel like the
video and comment with your favorite
superhero or villain so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 and if you'd like a chance to
win a Nintendo switch be sure to click
the link in the description down below
be sure to follow me on Twitter and
Instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof